Laugh and the world laughs with you
Fake laugh--and the world can tell
In the first cross-cultural experiment of its kind,
researchers asked 884 people
from 21 different cultures
in six regions around the world,
to listen to recordings of real, spontaneous laughter,
and fake, “volitional” laughter
recorded from US college-aged women.
Can you tell the difference?
Here’s fake
Here's real
Real
Fake
Now you can try guessing again
The first one was real (option 1)
So in the study,
on average, nearly two-thirds of listeners
in each culture could tell the difference
between real and fake laughs.
Genuine chuckles were
typically higher pitched and louder.
Similar characteristics are seen in cries
of pain and anguish.
Suggesting that real laughter is a more emotional
and primal response
that emerged early in human evolution.
The experiments show that despite cultural differences,
people perceive laughter in generally the same way
suggesting giggles and guffaws constitute a basic
and universal part of human behavior.